so the new song with LMA it seemed did
someone play you is that what happened
did
I mean people always play we just talked
about this we just talked about how I'm
saying were you like because at first of
all I I love the song because it's
definitely like a relatable song because
a lot of people try to act like they're
not jealous people but you know you know
like you're like oh drop all your [__]
or don't drop all your [__] but drop
off you drop all the [__] yeah so was
that something you actually went through
yeah so I've had that feeling so
so the thing about me is like I'm one of
those people that says I'm not a jealous
person where every by the way every
woman ever is that no no no but no
they're all I'm not jealous who the [__]
is this [__] liking your photos no you
can ask Christine that's my best friend
and my manager she's literally with me
every single day because she has to be
but you would choose
um but literally I'm not jealous the
only thing that I'm I get jealous about
which is so valid okay
is Instagram which is okay
liking other people's photos like other
[__] what kind of photos
I'm just asking I just have to ask like
okay if it's like a girl who's like bent
over and says Lincoln bio
yeah for sure I'd be that's a problem
but it's like
like girls that like you don't even know
like you don't even be knowing them and
they're like you know I I love a girl in
the Bikini pic I have a bikini pic we
all do it it's great right but if my
partner is liking that person's pictures
you don't even know her first of all
second of all she's not looking out for
you right she doesn't give a [__] if
you're liking her pictures so that's
that's the Line in the Sand for you yes
it's just like why because I'm okay with
like you looking at the picture enjoying
it and then scrolling like I know we all
but don't double tap don't double tap
why why do you have to go the extra mile
because you want attention so what do
you want the attention yeah what do you
want what do you want that person
what if they're just following the
person is that a problem
no
hmm no that's what I'm saying like I I
understand that we're attracted to
people right like do you follow like I'm
I'm trying to figure out what the female
equation or uh equivalent is to you know
guys will follow IG thoughts right are
there dude versions of that that I'm
just not hip to like are there guys with
like 12 like 12 packs I don't even think
that's real that'd be definitely
surgical if that's a thing I'm sure
there is but I don't want to see it I'd
be following the Instagram girls because
their women are just so much more
beautiful I agree so you'll follow the
IG women as well yeah okay so yeah okay
don't be tapping don't don't double tap
don't do it like just don't do it why
especially because it's like for nothing
right you're not you're not gonna get
that attention you're seeking you're
hoping that you get yeah yeah yeah and
then you look crazy because if like one
of your mutual friends is like sees that
they're liking their shoes your man is
over here double tapping Rosa acosta's
[__] ass [__] exactly and my worst
fear like I hate other people knowing
things about me that I don't know and
that's like the worst part you don't
want to feel you don't want to feel like
you're getting like yeah not hear you I
don't want to look like an idiot right
you know like I don't want other people
knowing [__] before me that was like the
most that was the worst part about being
cheated on the one time I was cheated on
I was like the most [__] up part was
that everyone knew except except you so
it was like they were like the friends
knew because it's I feel like it's like
a probably a different situation if like
your man is on vacation in Miami and he
hooks up with a stranger he's never
gonna see again sure you should hate
that and you should leave him for that
but it's not like if like this it's like
a thing a known thing yeah and
everyone's lying to your face and like
you're like what the [__] like I'm just
boo boo the fool at this point yeah no
it was like it was so bad like my like
this guy and his best friend had a
threesome basically with this girl
that's kind of that's how I got cheated
on and then his friend that he did it
with asked me to pick him up from the
airport before I knew hmm
um yeah yeah I don't know man yeah trash
I don't know if I you know could
participate
in such activities would you if I'm not
sure partner cheated on you right
wood
it hurt you more if they did it because
they loved the person or if they did it
because it was just like a one night
thing because they love the person
that would hurt more I think so yeah huh
what about you no that wouldn't hurt
more because you're like at least you
understand yeah it's like okay I can't
help that you love that person you had a
connection with that person at least
they're not wasting it you're like
there's some investment there and I hope
you live happily ever after yeah